of course  uh our thoughts and prayers are with the  family and it's uh  some i cannot even imagine how i must  feel it's it's absolutely  um  horrible just only to think about it and  um it's such a tragedy  um yes from  i said from our point of view whatever i  say would not help really but um  if we can help in any kind we will that  that's clear that must be clear  this is our city it's  usually we like to say  lfc city or the amazonian thing that  everton city but in these moments we  have really to to realize it's our city  and so whatever we can do together there  we have to do and um  uh  i don't like the  the moments when it happens but i like  the fact that we are then united and and  do really  um and support with all we have and um  how's that whatever we do it will not it  will not help follow for the moment will  not um  but  anyway you have to you have to try  to to ease the situation slightly if we  can do something we will do it